edgar le chat sourit fabienne janka
nenci ribard epsilon jeunesse
cela fait six mois quai de gare le chat
noir fait les poubelles pour trouver à
manger il sort la nuit de préférence à
l'heure où tous les chats sont gris
malgré sa discrétion il est souvent
prise en chasse par un homme mal
embouché ou un gros chiens du quartier
parfois en s'endormant il pense à la
chaleur de son foyer au canapé douillet
au grand bureau sur lequel ils
s'allongent et pendant que sa maîtresse
écrivait aux délicieuses pâtes et
qu'elle lui préparer à ces interminables
caresse alors et gars médard
certaines nuits il repense au décès de
sa maîtresse à ses héritiers qui se
chamaillent au bureau qu'ils se
disputent aux serrures qu'ils changent
et
chaque clan chasse
à présent la fin et train ses entrailles
et quand le jour éteint les étoiles le
froid le mort si fort
mes gars ne veut pas baisser les pattes
alors il se donne un défi trouver un
travail
hélas il a beau épluché attentivement
toutes les annonces aucune ne correspond
à son profil
chavirer edgar s'assied sur le trottoir
pour reprendre ses esprits et ses
espoirs
alors que la nuit tombe il aperçoit au
loin deux petites souris marchand toute
guillerette patte dessus pas de sous
quand quentin personnes tapies dans
l'ombre leur saute dessus elle lui
échappe habilement en éclatant de rire
intrigué par tant d'audace edgar leur
emboîtent le pas caché dans le noir ils
observent leur manège elle enfile une
lampe frontale et des chaussons de
feutrine s'arme d'un petit baluchon et
disparaissent dans les étages
au bout d'une dizaine de minutes les
deux sourires font leur apparition elle
s'installe pour conter leur butin une
demi douzaine de petites dans chacune
soudain la lumière s'allume bondissant
sous l'escalier et de gares et les
souris se retrouvent museau à museau
la pénombre revenus edgar tout
chambouler rompt le silence le premier
mais que faites vous avec toutes ses
dents tu n'as jamais perdu dans pas
vraiment c'est donc ça eh bien nous
sommes des petites souris je vois bien
mais elle éclate de rire petite souris
c'est notre métier la nuit venue nous
nous faufilons sous les oreillers pour
récolter les dents de lait et toi tu
fais quoi dans la vie
edgar embarrassé balbutie un chat dans
la gorge et bien c'est à dire qu'en ce
moment comment expliquer ce n'est pas
honteux pas avoir travail mais as-tu un
endroit où dormir et manger tu as ta
faim au moins
edgar n'a pas le temps de répondre son
estomac le fait à sa place et son
gargouillements déchire le silence ça te
dirait d'être une petite souris
vous plaisantez j'ai pas le profil
qu'est-ce que tu en sais pas d'abord je
n'ai pas la bonne couleur tu plaisantes
la nuit tous les chats sont gris je n'ai
pas la bonne taille ça c'est un détail
je n'ai pas stop stop stop l'interrompt
l'une des petites souris tu sais faire
pas douce pour attraper les dents sous
l'oreiller sans réveiller les enfants tu
sais grimper aux gouttières et tu as un
énorme avantage sur nous tu ne fait pas
peur aux parents bon admettons mais quel
patron voudrait deux mois
les deux petites souris se font un clin
d'oeil et répondant et répondent en
choeur te voilà embauché pour un essai
chez les soeurs dents du bonheur top là
et c'est ainsi qu'edgar le chat noir
devant une petite souris